[Applause]
I'm moving out of sober house in just a
few days you know it'll be Wendy Wendy
Williams breaks her silence after filing
for divorce from Kevin hunter last week
the talk-show host
spoke out on her show Monday reflecting
on the motto behind her hot topic
segment their business is our business
it's so crazy because now my business is
your business
[Music]
[Applause]
turnabout's a fair game I get it
Williams who recently revealed she is
living in a sober house said she had a
quote really good weekend with six of
her friends two of whom are her sponsors
you know I've been dealing with issues
with addiction alcoholism and I have a
whole new life that I planned for myself
and my son
[Applause]
believe me you when you lay in a room
with no TV and four gray walls all day
and no telephone at your already and you
lay there and you think about your life
this is my life at the sober house it's
one of the best things honestly that
could have ever happened to me the 54
year old who has been open about her
past addiction to cocaine said being
candid about her struggles on the show
has been important to her recovery you
wear a different mask when you're out
here yet everybody has including you
whether you're a secretary or a
schoolteacher whatever everybody has
things in their life that they are
embarrassed to share with the world and
addressing my sobriety
my addiction head-on has really helped
me sort out every single compartment of
my life I have a commitment to me and my
son to come out of here better stronger
and faster than ever
Williams filed for divorce from her
husband of 21 years last week amid
speculation that he has been cheating on
her with a woman who allegedly gave
birth to his baby last month rumors of
infidelity have plagued the couple for
years and while Wendy never confirmed
the gossip she did sort of address her
marital woes on her show in March I'm
still very much in love with my husband
you know marriages have abs and flows
marriages are not easy don't ask me
about mine until you see this gone now a
source close to Wendy tells ety quote
wendy is done she should have been done
a long time ago but she tried to make it
work
you